- [Instructor] In this
video, we're going to explore
how a two by two matrix can be interpreted
as representing a transformation
on the coordinate plane.
So let's just start with some examples
or some conceptual ideas.
So the first conceptual idea is that
any point on our coordinate plane here
and this of course is our X
axis and this is our Y axis,
can be represented by a
combination of two vectors.
You could have this
vector right over here.
That goes exactly one unit
in the horizontal direction.
We can represent that as a
vector like this, one, zero,
when you write a vector
vertically like this
the convention is that the top number here
is what we're doing in the X direction.
And then the bottom number,
the zero is what we're doing
in the vertical direction
or the Y direction, so this
is the one, zero vector.
And then this right over
here, what would we call that?
Well that we would call
the zero, one vector
because it doesn't go at
all in the X direction.
And it only goes up
one in the Y direction.
Now just to feel good that any
point on the coordinate plane
can be represented as a
weighted sum of these.
Let's just pick a point at random.
Let's say this point, all right over here,
let's call it point A.
And you could represent that as a vector
that looks something like this,
I'll do it as a dotted line,
but this could be represented
as a positional vector like that.
And of course, if we're
thinking about it in coordinates
we would just say this is at
the coordinate three comma one.
The X coordinate is a three,
the Y coordinate is one.
But if we wanted to express
it in terms of a vector,
we could write it out as three, one,
the X direction we're moving
three from the origin,
positive three and the Y direction
we're moving one to get there.
And you could see that
we can represent this
as a weighted sum of these two vectors.
We can write this as, this is
the same thing as three times
our one, zero vector, one, zero
plus one times our zero
one, vector zero one vector.
And you can see it visually,
this yellow vector that points
to point a right over there.
You can have three of this
vector, one, two, and then three.
And then one of the orange vector.
Now I said that I would
explain how two by two matrices
can represent a transformation.
And the way that you
could think about it is
if I have a two by two
matrix that looks like this,
so let me just draw the matrix,
where the first column is one, zero
and then the second column is zero, one.
This just tells you what to
do with these two vectors.
I know this might be a little
bit confusing at first,
but let's just walk through it together.
So the way I've represented it,
this first column says
what is the transformation
you want to apply to
this one, zero vector,
this first blue vector?
Well, we're just keeping it one zero.
So we're not changing it, it's the same.
One, zero vector here
one, zero vector here.
Likewise, zero, one vector
here, zero, one vector here.
So this two by two matrix
actually represents
what's sometimes known as
the identity transformation.
It maps any point on the
coordinate plane back to itself.
It doesn't change the points,
but I'm showing this because
now I'm going to show
a two by two matrix that represents
a non identity transformation.
For example, let me draw the matrix again.
So let's say I have the matrix,
instead of one, zero here I'm
going to write a two, one here
instead of a zero, one here
let me write a one, two.
So in this transformation,
what we're doing is
we're turning this one, zero
vector into a two, one vector.
You're going to see what I'm
talking about in a second.
So what does a two, one vector look like?
Let me do it in that color.
Well, we go two in the X
direction one in the Y direction.
So it's going to look like this,
it's going to look like that.
And then what does a one,
two vector look like?
Well, it goes one in the X direction
and then two in the Y direction,
so it looks like this.
And the way that this
represents a transformation
is that anything that was a weighted sum
of the one, zero and the
zero, one vectors originally,
you can now view as a
weighted sum of the two, one
and the one, two vectors.
And so we can now think
of another point A prime,
that's not going to be
three of the ones zeros
and one of the zero ones.
We can think of it as,
let me write it over here,
as three of the two, ones
plus one of the one twos,
one of these one, two.
So where would that put that now?
What we're going to go,
go three of the two, ones.
So this is one of them,
this is two of them
and then this is three of them.
And then I'm going to have
one of the one, two vectors,
this orange vector right over here.
And so I'm going to have one of those.
And so that will take me to A prime.
This is my new point
after the transformation,
I go to A prime.
So I've gone from this
point A to this A prime.
And this two by two matrix is
telling us how to transform.
Now we can do that with multiple points.
Now, if I talk about a
point here at the origin
that was originally at the origin point B,
well that's zero of the orange vector,
zero of the blue vectors.
So even after the transformation,
it's going to be zero
of the two, one vector
and zero of the one, two vectors.
So it's just going to stay in place.
It's just going to map to itself.
So B is equal to B prime,
and we could also imagine another point.
Let's say right over here,
let's call that point C.
Well point C is originally
two of the blue vectors
and none of the orange vectors.
So after the mapping, it'll
be two of the two, one vectors
and none of the one, two vectors.
So two of the two ones.
So if you go one, two, and
then none of the one, twos
you're going to get C
prime right over there.
And so notice, if originally
you had a triangle
between A, B and C, let
me draw it like this.
So originally you had
this triangle A, B, C
what is it now gotten mapped,
what is it now mapped to?
Well, it's now mapped to big triangle.
I'll do my best to draw
it relatively straight
so we land on target.
So that's that side.
And then we have this side
going from B prime to C prime
and then we wanna connect that
side from C prime to A prime.
Now you might be saying,
so how do you know that the
lines map onto other lines?
How do you know this transformation
didn't all of a sudden make
this line squiggly or zigzag?
And that's one of the
interesting properties
of the type of transformation
we're talking about.
A two by two matrix will
represent a linear transformation.
And there's two ways to think
about it in this context,
a linear transformation
will always map the origin
onto itself and it will always
map a line onto another line,
it won't turn that line into a curve,
or it won't make it zigzag somehow.
Now the last thing you
might be wondering is,
Hey what about all these transformations
we had from geometry, these
similarity transformations,
things like rotations
reflections, dilations,
can you do those with matrices?
And the simple answer is yes,
you can do them as long as
you keep the origin in place.
And you can actually
using a two by two matrix
come up with a whole series of
other linear transformations
that are much more, let's call it exotic,
than just the rotations,
reflections and dilations.